I think you and I need to have a project
together because we have a good
chemistry yep and oh we have it listen
we want to be the my sidekick for the
show on your talk show yeah this show
could be called my sidekick is Conan
O'Brien
and then on the t-shirts on the front
it'll say my sidekick is Conan O'Brien
starring Timothy Oliver right and on the
back it'll be like it'll say he needs he
he needs a friend yes so you incorporate
this is good we're getting the word out
on all the brands I see what we're doing
see we're doing and then your whole
thing will to be
it would I would love that are you in
yeah because you brought it up right you
said and I came back to you I'll be
honest with you I thought it was going
to be something maybe more in the acting
realm but if you want to actually this
is the problem you we've already
established this you want this life over
here but I I want over there so you want
to act together
yeah if you see a chance for us to be in
a project you see a chance
well you're a writer let's pitch
something all right what's going on with
writing by the way I was thinking about
this the other day now that you've been
yeah what is going on with right now but
you're you are a true blue genius writer
well I'm saying that for the people may
not be aware of it he's really good
talented that's sweet
have you
do you uh do you write right
anymore uh do you ever sit down and just
keep regular writing hours I don't no I
don't I like not go that's a bit of a
it's a bit of a I do write letters I
write letters to People by the way I've
heard you say this and if you gave me
your home address I I have a to-do
list
I'm writing this down now I write
letters to people and I I type them out
hold on and when people get one of my
letters I'm gonna tell you this note to
self okay I want you to hear it I want I
want there to be Witnesses
note to self
right Conan
a handwritten letter
saying you've heard he likes to write
people
handwritten letters typed funny because
you've never received one okay okay
I'm writing you I had a I meant I heard
you say this
talking Sedaris yeah by the way
you and Sedaris people do yourself a
favor if they're still listening to this
interview
those interviews I just love them yeah I
think I may have I don't know if I've
told you that but I just love you guys
talking to each other
um I uh and I heard you talking about
how much you like to type letters to
people yeah and I remember thinking I
should write Conan a letter and tell him
that I heard that and yet I wondered why
I'd never gotten one well maybe yours is
coming and maybe it's going to be really
special there's a lot of grievances here
in the Friendship today I realize you
and I have not connected for a long time
it's been a while you've been busy and I
think uh a little bit I think maybe I
came into this with a chip on my
shoulder a little bit well but I
probably did a little bit and
um it's good that you admit it you know
I felt like I had to use the podcast to
get you back into my life and then felt
like you played me like a chump a chimp
you know and you taught your big big
talker about Nolo or no law but we all
know it wouldn't happen if I called you
up and said hey I'm coming suddenly you
did be an issue you know
oh they just canceled Jazz Fest counting
on this is this is no no one's buying
this I'm not buying it no one listen no
one's listening I could be excited if I
was coming down yeah I'm gonna come see
you and I'm gonna get up on stage and
Scat with the band
a scoot got scooted yeah yeah for those
who haven't been to Jazz Fest I highly
recommend it it's my favorite music
festival and it's not all Jazz but it's
the best thing you also go in the gospel
tent and just listen to gospel that's
nice that's my favorite things in the
world I still feel like the best way for
us to do something acting wise
is if we write something okay but you've
given up writing I didn't say I gave up
on it didn't he used those words you
said don't you do regular writing every
day and I said I write letters but no
I'm not sitting down every day and going
the sun broke lazily Over the Horizon in
a crepuscular burst of Auburn light you
know I I didn't do that she says that
was crazy that's amazing just
write that down I've got that recorded
that's an amazing beginning to a really
awful book but it's a great beginning
yeah but but awful book but not an awful
um what do we want to do we're gonna do
something together right is it going to
be like a half hour kind of deal how the
the thing that they're going to want us
to do is they're going to want us
they're going to want us to do the buddy
cop thing you and me buddy wants to do
buddy they're gonna want us to do it and
they're going to want you to be the one
that knows what he's doing and me to be
like
let's flip it yes I'm hyper competent
super good killer with the ladies wasn't
there like a uh didn't Jeff Goldblum
have a a cop show for a while where he
was a cop uh 10 speed and brown shoe oh
my God yeah that's it with Ben Vereen
that's it yeah what let's just remake
that let's bring that back people love
people love uh re whatever there are
reboots yeah let's bring back 10 10th
Street and uh what would you call it 10
speed and brown shoe that's awesome
yeah you're so you're not going to be at
this pitch meeting you can't even say
you can't say a whole sentence correctly
involving this pitch so I'm gonna go in
and Pitch it I love the pitch but I'm
gonna say Tim Oliphant is attached I'm
aging quickly and badly I could see it
in your face when you saw me
um so I need to get this done now do you
know what I mean this can't wait two
years three years well use it though use
that in your performance what that I'm
falling apart and old did your aging
badly and you don't have a lot of time
like you're the cop who needs to solve
this thing because they've like but not
because he has a terminal disease or
he's about to retire just because he
doesn't like the way he's aging and he's
vain I like that idea it's really smart